hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play sonic dot exe
I opened up the game before and I saw
that and before I could start recording
before still I uh
I kind of wanted to make sure that that
got in there I like this game
anyway so someone suggested this this is
based off of a creepypasta about someone
who found like a cartridge of Sonic and
there was obviously something wrong with
it if you couldn't tell
so let's go I didn't read the
creepypasta other than then like a few
okay games like this like a really
messed up inhaling mess with my head man
I don't I don't know
okay can't go that way how do I jump
don't even need to chill
oh god that music Jesus surprised you go
away I am very concerned an old
everywhere
Oh God oh god no
oh no no and the flowers and the blood
in them
and the music geez fight it shop what is
up oh yeah no I got him
it's not going no wait you're an idiot
hello do you want to play with me no
rather go have a beer fun that's all the
same hide-and-seek
no oh god this is hell
why in hell now I go left now I can I
can go oh no
crying why am i crying I can't move I'm
just crying Oh going on with this get
him would you slow want to try again no
I'll have that beer I talked about
before I didn't know tails had such a
feminine scream it tails is dead and in
Hell now crazy I like this game you
suggested it I don't know
all right we'll see a kidnap
with the power of flight but a long time
since I played Sonic games you can't run
like hell I can't let me go oh I am slow
hey I thought tail or knuckles was much
faster than this I don't even know why
there's a rings meter in a score or the
time this time this is how long I've
been playing still can't jump or
anything and I know Sonic's right around
the corner what happened to sonic haha
blender
oh that is lovely cartoon blood
everywhere all those pipes down there or
there pumping blood that's good that's
good yeah I guess that's some barren
hellscape in the background ah
Tintin Tintin - Oh found you but I don't
even get a chance to run away now ah ah
Jesus cries with you good wine look here
run away
I'll run toward you you [ __ ] ah no [ __ ]
you I'm gonna getcha I'll getcha [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh oh
so many souls to play with so little
time
would you agree I mean no knuckles had
such an effeminate scream I bet Eggman
has the most effeminate of all dr.
Eggman professor Eggman in a while
something tells me this isn't uh this
isn't a Sega approved Sonic game
oh hi heck pen oh let me go let me go
have a pretty little battery bull oh I'm
sorry backwards this is normal
don't turn around that thing standing
directly behind you will just get pissed
off okay well what's some chains they're
actually this music isn't that bad
it's like old-style dramatic Castlevania
music here weird blue flame Rorschach
patterns of blood on the wall dr. grant
sliding backwards perfectly normal
nothing wrong with that don't know what
I did how did I know I just like can't
do that how did I how did I do that how
did I do that
oh there I go if I slide backwards I
can't possibly be in trouble right right
pingas pingas pingas pingas oh hi
okay once again I can't do anything hey
oh hi I am God you might want to brush
your teeth there god it's at the end is
at the end of the game is this where
sonic steals my soul please could I
could I go home now arrrrrr that's weird
you're weird Sonic
no I'm not ready for round two geez let
me go home let me go back to my oh hello
oh that's the doom background oh oh okay
um crit game created by crimson the bat
holy hell man what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you man make it a game
like this I guess oh hello everybody I
press these do that I bet even the
escape button yeah even the escape
button leads to that one ha ha ok I
guess that's the end of the game it's
probably gonna make me all that for this
but oh man I was messed up and oh oh oh
there's more is there more what's this
just the end of the game I can't read
this it's in some strange foreign
language Masonic in the background I
think that says I am God a bunch in the
background what a self-absorbed douche
okay that screen doesn't pop up when I
skis again but it's at the end can
someone who speaks Japanese please
translate this for us
I think this Japanese if I'm not
mistaken I might be mistaken Japanese
Chinese no is that Chinese I can't tell
think that might be Chinese yeah that's
Chinese sorry sorry Japanese feel or if
it's I don't know I math Korean actually
know these ago I know that it's not
Korean that's all I know
so anyway if someone who can read this
translate it please do I'm guessing I
guess that's the end of the game so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for videos that I've done
waiting re okay I guess that's it so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
Wow good that is not normal I know a lot
of things that are normal and that is
not what didn't quite get that Oh